blow is heading to Las Vegas how will
this change things well I mean we're
right in the middle of shooting our Las
Vegas season and it's a pretty sexy
season I would say there is sexier it's
sexier there's a lot more to accept men
nudity and like you know our show has
always been about women's bodies and the
way that that changes these characters
being in Vegas I think everyone feels a
little more open we all noticed saying
what happens in Vegas stays in Vegas I
think all the characters are feeling
that a little bit
what makes clothes such a great show to
binge to sit down and watch like an
entire season in one Saturday it's a fun
show to watch there are so many
characters you're bound to relate to
someone
we have wrestling it's set in the 80s
it's like really great eye candy but the
characters are wonderful and I think the
stories are really sweet and positive
and even though we sort of dump deeper
and deeper into these people in general
I think it's a really optimistic show
and that's something we need right now
so you said that in Las Vegas things are
getting a little sexier a little more
naked naked Vegas how do you prepare for
that do you do extra or you just like
okay today's my courage today I've got
them you know we're all in such great
shape wrestling on the show actually
they're shooting it I don't think much
about my body at all we have such a
powerful group of women that we work
with and everybody nobody has body
issues we need food and we have fun so I
think I got actually I was going to be
excited about the nudity and stuff like
that this season because when I'm
shooting the show is when I feel my most
powerful yeah
[Music]
did you draw double dots on your face
this was a tough role for you actually
because he was such a unique voice how
did you come up with her gosh I think
you know in the first movie what
attracted me to the role of unikitty was
that she seems to be all smiles and
rainbows and bubble baths but has a
really dark aggressive side and it felt
very unexpected and very funny and I
think in the second movie you'll see
that you channeled outside a lot more
some of us a little separate character
named ultra caddies who is the unit
Kitty's alter-ego and it's really fun to
play it's really hard all by voice of
every rose I just think that stuff for
the end of our recording sessions and
then I'm just like screaming but it's
definitely a side of myself I don't
channel that often so it's fun release
in here yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]